hello sir there's no way I guarantee he
will but I didn't think of him he could
see you can I ask you a question Neil
deGrasse Tyson aren't you in the middle
of a conversation yes we were talking
about my shirt actually we were going to
ask you would you be caught dead in that
t-shirt he's wearing in that in that
ridiculous looks like a third-grader
printed it bobby fisher' t-shirt oh it's
a Bobby yeah I see it is Bobby Fischer
yeah now I'm not asking if you like
Bobby Fischer I'm asking you if you'd be
caught dead in that ridiculous it's a
lot it's not you know and in the world
of current t-shirts that's not you'd not
find that on the list no it's probably
not the most aesthetically pleasing no
the design quality is not quite there
not at all do you play two different
pictures I do but my son started beating
me when he was 10 so I've realized I was
are you lousy or is he a prodigy okay
did a little of both and if the kid
there's some kid they just mastered by
the time they're like 9 years old it's
just like yeah yeah when he was like 14
or 15 he was done and went on to other
things but no debates like trophies and
stuff but they give you trophies if you
come in 10th place you know there's like
a trophy city at these like kids
tournaments but do you feel about that I
you know I hate saying in my day you
know you got a trophy for winning what
am I saying I was doing a crossword
puzzle once for for the New York Times
and one of the clues was to come in
second and you're looking about that to
the wind play show you know what's the
word you need for that and you know what
the answer was to lose yeah right
incredible right so if you start giving
awards for not coming in first then you
can one could ask what's your incentive
for improving or getting just getting
better at all
so but that's that's sort of old-school
talking yeah you know times change and
people get get trophies for
participating and I'm who might say had
I not been a kid now that I wouldn't
totally delight in that so I mean you'd
like it but maybe you wouldn't be
motivated to be great yeah I'm just
being good is enough I've got it yeah
I've got to say I don't know that that
motivates anybody right if you're
awarded rewarded for for just being
there or does it make people repulse
people who might not shine more likely
to shine because they feel like they're
not gonna lose and then they wind up
doing it I don't know what the thinking
is I don't have kids but I don't know
yeah yeah I know I know so I'm again I
why not to bring old school into new
school just because it's you know that's
what my parents did back when I you know
there's always some grown-up telling you
that you're you're not you know you
don't relate so everybody thinks it's
different now though because like it
makes sense in your head whereas your
parents think didn't so back in their
day that didn't make sense but back in
your nation there's a line in West Side
Story where some adult is telling the
you know the hoodlums you know when I
was your age we and and the reply was
you were never our age you are you you
seem like a competitive guy are you
competitive I no no no I mean not
against other people competitors myself
if I'd do something and I think I can do
it better I'll try to do it better or if
they're people who have a talent or
expressed in whatever way that talent is
I will aspire to that talent but it's
not to beat them it's just to improve
myself so so get mad when you see them
doing well like that's good figure out
how to do that I don't know about that I
saw you and Matt Serra wrestling around
I guess I was right there for I could
see that was China hosting that show
yeah we were wrestling on the ground so
in wrestling so here's here's the rest I
used to wrestle right and that's like
the purest of sports you can't blame a
piece of equipment you can't blame a
fellow team member for fumbling the ball
it is you and your opponent and anytime
I lost I say wow that was a good move
that move again right but again it's not
so I can divide and conquer and no it's
just can I get better
what was your record as a wrestler I was
undefeated I was undefeated in high
school Oh captain of my team and but
mind you that was the Bronx High School
of Science show but but then in college
I had actually losing record until my
senior year and so but so by the way I
was really good at rowing and in college
that growing was like the sport of the
gods
and I had the choice of being one of the
best rowers who just being sort of an
average or even slightly below average
wrestler but I weigh more enjoyed
wrestling as a contest and I stuck with
that I did that yesterday wrote in the
gym rowing let me ask you a question a
very long arm so that probably is
helpful that very much helps because you
want the oar in the water for the
longest arc you possibly can but when
you're rowing like that how long can you
do that for because like literally in a
minute and 40 or a minute and 50 seconds
and I'm like wiped out like what you
guys are training with you're the
benchmark here against which all aerobic
conditioning is amazing yeah that's
probably a fair point I was just kind of
dr. Tyson I would chat about it so the
wrong stroke is a highly thought about
thing in a in a in a rowing scholar and
in the in the sweeps and so the time it
takes you to pull through the water that
needs to be less than the time it takes
you to recover otherwise your body's not
gonna recover from having done that
stroke and if you try to speed up your
stroke rate by rushing forward to get
the oar back in the water
you're not taking advantage of the your
capacity to recover from the stroke so
it's a and then you slowly move forward
so I kind of slowly move forward now you
can speed up that entire process but the
ratio of the time it takes you to slide
forward so the time you are in the water
should remain such that you can recover
on each truck and if you do that then
you can you can really punch this out
for the full 10,000 meters how far is
10,000 me I don't know five ten thousand
meters how many miles is that my like a
10k run tank here run 10k I don't know
10k my father used to jog yeah I don't
believe it or not I was not an athlete
6.2 miles oh that's a lot of rowing yeah
yeah it is too much yeah and it's great
and it's you know as some of the rowing
facilities described it wants you to row
rather than cycle for your aerobics they
for your cardio again that's a you know
new term cardio cardio so they'll say
it's every muscle
every stroke so when you can so this is
the this is the celebration of this if
you're on a treadmill you know what are
you doing for your arms nothing there
dangling there unless you sort of carry
weights on the treadmill on our bicycle
what are you doing you know is your
lower back in that one I don't know I
don't think so is your easier or your
shoulders in it no I say just tense the
whole rowing is essentially every every
stroke every every muscle when you were
undefeated and you lost the first time
did it affect you at all no oh you you
were okay with it why you keep thinking
I have some psychological issues
honestly no I don't I was just curious
no no I like I said losing is the
indication that I should get better if I
need to and want to and I would see how
I lost a person quicker than I was do
they know more moves were they more was
it muscle memory right would I'd have to
think it through and are they stronger I
knew they were not more limber because
that was pretty well struck really
stretched guy I could do full splits and
things so it wasn't matter of Limburg
limber and I was also pretty strong
except my height is 6 to at my weight I
wrestled 190 pounds other wrestlers at
my weight were almost always shorter
than I was 6 feet 5 10 5 9 and since
we're exactly the same weight if you run
the numbers on this they will have
bigger muscles than I will because we're
the same weight and they're shorter
right and the strength of a muscle goes
as the cross-sectional area of the
muscle itself so so they would be
stronger than I was in any given moment
so I have to be quicker or clever right
and this is what I have to work on but
that's that and that way you improve and
in fact in fact people who are the best
I don't know if they have motivation to
improve if you're just always beating
everybody well that's the reason I ask
you about losing can I always fear
there's so much pressure with an
undefeated record like when people go
undefeated for a while the only would be
pressure because you're the one to beat
and everyone's after you yeah yes yes
normally I'd it's not the kind of life I
led it's also very healthy though to be
like to look at a loss and instead of
looking at a guy and being like oh how
do I get as good as him I'm never gonna
be
you bring it back to yourself and be
like what are the specific skills they
lost me I I thought that's what
everybody did until I saw people get
really pissed off when they lost uh-huh
and I said can't you just honor how much
better the other person was than you it
isn't that so is that what you realize
that science works for you because you
are not like the most emotional guy on
Planet it helps
although there's still quite a bit of
emotion in science if you make a
discovery
you're jumping through the roof I mean
there's not like we are emotional s
right but when it comes to God
that almost never happens by the way
really just FYI
don't say Eureka you don't want to know
when I yell so Isaac Asimov once wrote
that it's no it's not Eureka that people
say that sorry to say it's hmm that's
odd I didn't see that I did yeah and
that's where you learn that's where you
realize something is inconsistent with
your expectations you get a result from
the experiment that nobody thought was
gonna happen he said that and you start
to get a rush when you're like oh my god
this is you focus on that and you'd
perform another experiment you call up
others and so that yeah there's hardly
ever ru Rika moment plus plus I know
movies like this but then I get in it
the the midnight oil lone genius solving
the greatest problem in the world most
problems today are collaborative and
they don't make as tight a story that is
told right so there's stories in science
that I think should people should know
about but no one's gonna do them because
they don't talk about the one lone
genius whose networks heard one
good-looking hero with glasses I know
it's like vh1 when they did the the rock
documentaries and there's that trademark
phrase and then they were addicted to
drugs until they were cuz you know
there's always some point where
otherwise they're not even doing the
story on you right if you would like
we're married had kids you know two-car
garage and that was your rock home
no no behind the music you don't see it
behind the music on Kenny Rogers or
something who's had a nice career
towards the one hip guy who all the
sudden did heroin and went to jail like
that's the interesting story right right
I have a specific space question for you
about Jupiter you know I'm writing I'm
tickled when you were just just you were
up at night with us question waiting to
hand me yes this is great work on
Jupiter Paul you know 10 hours or a
rotation what's the pressure just don't
let that go shine earth takes 24 hours
to rotate once as we all know okay
actually takes 23 hours and 56 minutes
that detail is not important in this
conversation just later on on another
show I'll tell you we take 20 Earth
rotates once every 23 hours and 56
minutes and four seconds Wow but so is
call it 24 hours and so it's the
rotation that gives us the energy to
circulate storms with the ferocity they
have it's called the Coriolis force and
I tweeted once about the effect of the
Coriolis force on a kick in on a winning
kick in the over time of a football game
because it'll affect anything that is
airborne like clouds moving north south
so there was a kicker whose kick was
deflected one-third of an inch to the
right and ended up going in and well
went in they said oh we just kind of
lucky bounce off the left post no earth
helped that so I don't like freaked out
and was like made that Cincinnati
headlines and everything cuz with the
Bengals I think that won that game but
any of so I'll jump etre yes it is
bigger has higher gravity and rotates
once in 10 hours so you want to talk
about the the the ferocity of a Coriolis
force Jupiter's got it and Jupiter has a
storm it's called it's this huge red
spot that's on its surface and we call
it Jupiter's red spot that's how we roll
yeah spots on the Sun we call them
sunspots right see say we're into one
syllable communication in my field as
opposed to Jim's penis spots I don't
know the spot spot
so so you that red spot is a storm and
it's been raging for 300 years my
question about Jupiter when you going I
know that we sent a probe in and they
know it seemed to get crushed as it gets
closer but if you accept that happened
to Saturn always on Saturn 13 on Jupiter
Saturn we didn't send a probe to Jupiter
did but it's not crashing its Saturn all
the news of recent weeks is Saturn I
know this is a long time ago this is a
while ago I thought there was whoa okay
yeah we might put Galileo in there
Galileo was the name of a probe that
went to Jupiter and there was something
that went down into the Jupiter
atmosphere and they took measurements
until it got yeah but if you if you
could get the gig you into some kind of
a contraption that would let you go
lower on Jupiter what would you see as
you went further down well almost all
the way down and it gets denser and
denser and denser and it gets hotter and
hotter and hotter and yeah and we think
we know what the composition of Jupiter
is but it's nice to know in detail you
know this layer this layer this layer
the exact rate that that happens we have
model we can model it but to have the
data is always better than then then
your what your expectations might be but
you couldn't land off there's nowhere to
send anything that could land on it'll
be a point where the density of the gas
because it's so dense has the same sort
of densities you for example and then
you'll just sort of float there buoyant
oh okay yeah yeah but there's no like
surface as we know it yeah well if you
go fart it probably has a rocky well oh
no the pressures are so great that
hydrogen becomes metallic amazing if you
out of you remember your chemistry class
hangout appeared on both the left and
the right side of the periodic table I
don't if you remember this no yeah
because hydrogen has properties of
metals under certain conditions such as
very high pressures such as what you'd
get in the center of Jupiter so so no
it's it's its gases that is the action
is the active thing here and so but I
thought you were talking about Cassini
Cassini like days ago oh no no crashed
into it actually vaporized into into
Saturn how far down does it get before
it happened I don't know but I do know
that it's I was going 75 thousand miles
an hour
and yeah and all that energy has to go
somewhere as the gas slows it down and
wears ago goes back into the craft
itself then what happened in people with
asteroids coming through any atmosphere
they slow down and the kinetic energy
pumps back into the object it heats up
and it can heat up catastrophically so
that asteroids coming to earth will just
explode but in that case it vaporized
and every atom in Cassini's crafte ended
up becoming part of Saturn and I tweeted
Cassini VIP vaporized in peace when like
ships come back in like the one that
came in through the atmosphere was at
the endeavor that which one is no which
one blew up at 200,000 feet because the
heat shield was messed up it was a
couple years ago it came apart coming
back and talking about Columbia coming
is there is zero there's always the
thing they say if you don't get the
angle right when you're coming back in
that you can in a way kind of bounce off
that is that true yeah that can happen
you have two angles too shallow and but
no not with space shuttles because
specials are already in orbit around
Earth we're talking about coming back
from the moon I'll come back from the
moon you have the right trajectory so
that you can get pulled into the down
through the atmosphere if you come a
little too shallow you'll just skim off
the atmosphere and keep going like a
skimmed rock you throw a rock at the
right angle at the right shape across
the surface of water
the rock is way denser than water and
yet you can just pop off the top and
keep you know and keep skimming so oh
wow so you come in in one angle you burn
and if you come in at the other angle
you bounce off
yeah but the burning is that you have
heat shield so you protect yourself
that's the whole point of the heat
shield I'm just amazed they figured that
out on the Apollo they're like on the
foot where they were doing like hand
calculations yeah oh yeah well yeah plus
they had a slide rule you get it made in
the shade went with a slide in my high
school I'm old enough to have been
formally trained on Iceland on slide
rules I I never had the slide well I did
have a T Square t square also as you
were good at shot at at mechanical
drawing always that was for a scientific
calculator where you could put Tetris on
it so oh really yeah that's really what
it was for the day in the day did you do
you think we should be spending more say
so my high school
so so I went to a nerdy high school and
so if the bigger your slide rule would
be on like your holster leather where'd
you get one I still have it do you think
that we should be spending sending more
people into space and walking on the
moon and doing all that stuff that we
used to do because you see all these
like space movies about people going
into space and there seems to be all
this great stuff going on but you never
hear about people actually human beings
yeah a little part of me exploring
worries that Hollywood is so good at
pretending we're in space that we're
just okay with that poking books like
how did he know the first letter of each
book from the other side I always
wondered that that's probably something
you learn in space the other side of a
row of books how do you know what the
hell books you're pushing through that
was one of my questions about the movie
it's a great question yeah but so he
wasn't seeing the binder the but like
the page party was seeing the other side
right and so how's he gonna know how to
how to like do Morse Morse code with the
books what does anything to bring up
when you're watching with like your wife
or a friend or something like this
emotional climax comes forward how would
you know about I like the movie but
let's be honest did he say Murph enough
times we got it we got it but but if you
look at the Martian you know right the
representation of his challenges and his
travails you felt like you were there
yes and if Hollywood is perfect that I
wonder if our urges to want to do that
ourselves would evaporate but as opposed
to vaporize for a different deal yeah so
so I will not tell people what they
should want to do here it is there's a
quote from Antoine de saint-exupéry
who's a French author aviator from a
hundred years ago was the first real
writer who flew so he got to describe
what like among the clouds for the first
time in in a compelling way and he's
credited with this quote he said if you
want to if you want to build a ship
do not gather people have them find wood
and and show them tools no instead teach
them to yearn for the immensity of the
sea right so people need to want to see
space exactly
get up there and then you see yeah let's
do this let's fun NASA let's elect an
official who can do this and all the
rest of that just comes in behind it
right and if you put if you're starting
well let me how do you do this and I
don't know and it'll never get done
so you need people to just be you wanna
be there we want to be in space right
and and we Kennedy said it's put a man
on the moon return him safely to earth
before the decade is that he didn't say
let us build an agency to do this in
heaven and let his contract right with
it's not what he said right it's not
what he said
I just want you to make sure I'm sorry
oh yeah yeah yeah I want to take people
you're promoting the show it's a star
talk it's season four on that leave a
season four I just done can't even
believe it it's amazing Star Trek did
not last four seasons start talks better
Star Trek went three seasons was
canceled okay and some of your guests
you had an amazing guest list and we
talked before you got here about
abdul-jabbar yeah I love Kareem how was
he as a guest Oh God first he's smart
isn't all get it I've never seen him on
Jeopardy
the guy's out of control and watch Jeff
bait i watch jeopardy it's great said
that like he's proud of this I'm a
Family Feud guy sometimes the answers
are funny
[Laughter]
don't ever say proudly that I'm not a
jeopardy guy no I watch it in the cab
but then they may it's like a literacy
test in the cab you can't get that wrong
in the cab you're sitting in a when the
game show but my family's on Family Feud
did you see it no see you can't be that
much of a fan celebrity Family Feud
how'd you guys so how'd you do bust it I
didn't watch it don't tell me I'm a
Family Feud fan apparently not well I'm
not last time you were in we were
talking about match game and I was like
that was not your that was not yours
your lane to be in like you do well in
so many other
to me apparently I didn't mess up that
badly but we were on family feud how did
you guys do uh we won I hope so yeah
yeah yeah yeah I did the final round
with my son who in that in the city yeah
yeah who you up again glorious hit a
hair yeah so I was we were up against
who's the guy the the the former got a
play for the Lakers
Magic Johnson Michael Cooper ramus Rick
fire Rick Fox Rick Fox in his family
right very handsome family his his his
sister was like a euro swimsuit model
and he was a model after he so so we
were all there and it was we were duking
it out he has a son who's a total nerd
yes also on it and so we were you know
sharing some nerd moments but any so we
went family for everyone and win money
for charity was there is there anything
that gives you less faith in humanity
than watching jeopardy and then watching
Wheel of Fortune come on I'm the
interesting pair Wheel of Fortune has
got to be the stupidest show I've ever
seen in my life I started watching these
shows it's in his 80th season I can't
believe and I'm like really entertained
by it nowadays like I really enjoy
watching jeopardy and then Wheel of
Fortune comes on and I'm like what this
I love a good wheel afford they're
idiots here's the thing that happened
there was an episode of Jeopardy with
Kareem Jabbar where the question was
which country in Europe has the largest
land area okay and he answered what was
it I think he answered Sweden okay
although that was a mistake it's not
what he wanted to he knew what he wanted
he just said the wrong word that's wrong
in any measure okay someone else said it
was Spain or France when I forgot was
right but he then said but wait a minute
they have the sovereignty over Greenland
and if you add Greenland to that bada
bing so what he meant to say was Denmark
so he got it wrong but for the wrong
reason I mean he knew his answer was
Denmark he he misspoke but he got it
wrong too
about it exactly and I forgot how they
played that out I think they should have
given it to him cuz he knew all about
Greenland as a and you know how I
remember I reminded myself that
Greenland is is Denmark sovereign
because in the movie arrival mm-hmm one
of the arrival ships right was in
Greenland and they had flags where all
the ships were and the Danish flag was
there in Greenland and I was reminded of
this rack in arrival was that the one
with the giant egg yes I actually like
that that was a weird movie right weird
aliens were talking in like looking like
inkblots yes that made some sense to me
it was a septa pod right yes seven so so
here's what I wondered about that the
other you are making symbols on the
glass right right right
and here we are interpreting them how do
we know it's not backwards well you have
to assume though that they understand if
they understand all that and they can't
let a nuclear weapon go off in the ship
without a problem
and they have control you have to figure
they figured that out something yeah
that's all I'm saying right you're
assuming stuff and I'm not I don't make
those kind of assumption well here's
what I might it then would have been a
great moment in the movie oh it's not
that this is happening before that it's
happened in the other way time was kind
of weird for them in some area so she
may have learned how to read it at some
point in the you know it was time was
very interesting leagues backwards it
could change the arrow of time even time
still remains circular that's all I'm
saying
so you so my point is so he's smart
smart is all goodness he writes a column
he's written books and cram it in movies
and in in star talk it's kind of a geek
safe space yeah so so you learn we're
with our celebrity guests if they've got
some geek in them we're gonna find it
and we're gonna reveal it so I find out
yes he's been in a couple of movies you
know he was in in an airplane airplane
pilot he was also in one of the Bruce
Lee films became a big film Game of
Death and so I said he said he just
really wanted to be an actor like
professionally I said dude you're like
ten feet tall no he always wanted to be
Chewbacca
yes that makes perfect sense perfect
sense except for an odd thing to want
when you're the highest scorer in NBA
history I just was done being the
highest scorer you know how do you find
any geekiness and Katy Perry and Katy
Perry
okay yes so Katy Perry's another one of
the guests and Katy Perry we learned you
know she left school at 15 with a GED
never went to college and for many
people like that they're kind of done
learning and now they just have their
life whatever that life is well she's
got a life but folded into that is a
deep curiosity for everything she does
not yet know and this is a curiosity
that we have his childhood it's in our
childhood and it as a curiosity that
scientists have because we never lost it
from childhood and there she is a pop
singer one of the Papas singers there is
and she is wondering I'm there and she
knows I know some stuff and she said
well tell me about this and how does
math does math matter in the universe
and how and why and it turned out to be
a session with her asking me questions
and so yes it was a it was a it was a
celebration of curiosity in the face of
someone who had an entire other career
and her career is not even about that
right but that's what it is but as a
person she had that as a person she had
that and one of her songs
sounded to me like she wants have sex
with an alien so I had to get into that
China I got to see the show to find out
I got a see a question for you to hear I
was thinking that as you were talking
about how she was asking you questions
like you're great because if people
would want to ask you stuff because you
know about things that none of us do so
you're kind of the go-to guy in any
situation who's like that for you like
when usual people who but who do you who
is somebody that you just love sitting
there and listening to you back to your
earlier point I love nothing more than
sitting around people who know more
stuff than I do right and then I can
just learn right so almost any one of my
professional astrophysics colleagues
knows more about multiple things than I
do and any time I'm in their presence
we're talking about it I've got there's
a
a I've got a a research scientist in my
department who who's like an expert in
sort of energy systems and energy
delivery and energy production and we're
doing some renovations in our home and I
think I'm getting solar panels is that
do this and consider this and in the end
then the net metering does this and then
and so it's a whole conversation what
kind of pumps and an inverse pump to
this so so almost any one of my
colleagues because you look at me and
you think I'm some kind of exception
magic man except and and I sometimes I
wear my my funky ties you know with
planets and moons on space if you come
to one of our astrophysics conferences
that's camouflage yeah you can't say Oh
show me give me the guy who had a time
no we are all wearing the time well so
so so it and by the way that's a general
truth about people who are academics we
have devoted our lives to learning
something new every single day and so
but most people don't even know an
academic who's an academic it's a
professor who is an expert who teaches
who's at a university most people don't
even know an academic so so this is why
when research happens in universities
and we tell you people are warming the
earth it's time to listen right right
these this information comes from
research centers and people devoted
their lives to learning something
tomorrow that we did not know today well
somebody's asking on the phone as you
say that has family in Puerto Rico does
Neil know why all these storms are
happening and that's why I'm with what
you're saying well some of it's just bad
luck in terms of the you know the luck
of the draw cuz storms there's a sort of
a randomness to them it's odd however
that by the way if you look at the you
know storms are named alphabetically did
you if you don't know you don't know
okay
so that just would they go right down
the alphabet and they switch between
girl names and boy names all right so
that what they knit then they name
tropical depressions that become
tropical storms and occasionally become
hurricanes it look at the names of all
the recent hurricanes
they're all consecutive in the alphabet
so not a one of them only ended life as
a tropical storm they all wrecked up and
became hurricanes and you are more
likely to have strong hurricanes when
you have a warmer atmosphere and a
hotter planet because the ocean is where
that energy is coming from and the at
energy rises up and warm moist unstable
air is the recipe for storms and then
you get the Coriolis force spinning them
around and you drive the intensity of
these storms so so yeah I mean this is a
shot across our bow how much time you
think the planets got left I'd say about
20 minutes so yeah our earth is pissed
off alright yeah if you want to look at
it and that front in those terms if so
it's not how long earth has earth will
be here earth will survive everything I
mean it's there was a time when all
carbon that is currently underground was
not on the ground and it was in the
atmosphere and there was no ice anywhere
on earth it was in the time of the
dinosaurs there were no ice caps nothing
we could return to that era but if we
did then you melt all the ice in
Greenland that'd be great for Denmark
because there's more land but a bellyful
of ice in Greenland and Antarctica and
if you do that then the water levels
will rise and reach the bottom elbow of
the Statue of Liberty the Statue of
Liberty's left elbow really that's how
high up the water would be so it's a
different world you lose every single
city that ten thousand years of
civilization created on the water's edge
in the service of man of Commerce
transportation say we don't change
anything how long do you think we have
left on the planet as humans if we don't
kill ourselves with total nuclear how
much change or invent some kind of nano
bot that replaces us decides it doesn't
need us that's it's gonna happen because
we're a virus on earth what happened
yeah it may happen what am i imitating
your virus my doctor
after you look at the spots arrogation
on the wheel or impression though no
that was the other guy I don't matter
you were virus I haven't seen it the
Smith's name is at the actors name now I
don't I do not you know you should see
you should see that movie Hugo Weaving
yeah Hugo Weaving and he's also the
voice of V in series what's that Vandana
V for Vendetta yes yeah yes voice
probably his body it wouldn't have to
have been but because it wasn't James
Earl Jones in the costume of Darth Vader
right what he had done back though for
this last one and in James's so you
could tell if you remember that the
prequel that they shot Darth Vader scene
but they you could tell they still used
James Earl Jones but he sounds a little
but I mean again he's forty years ago
he's had an amazing career so far but
you sound different today than you do
that's what I mean you can kind of tell
there's still the same actor but a
little a little older see that movie
that movie mother is a complete metaphor
for what what man is doing to earth and
destroying it and how you know like I
said earth will survive us so don't
worry about the earth you have to worry
about life on earth human life on earth
and the average life expectancy of a
mammal species there's a couple of
million years and we're actually very
early in that time time arc our species
we've been sort of anatomically human
for a few hundred thousand years and we
still got crow man yes a lot of time in
front of us if we don't kill ourselves
do you feel that we'll be able to like a
you know a greatest advantage is that we
are living everywhere on earth so
generally catastrophes are regional
local and so so we just hope they
wipeout them and we're still I'm hoping
it doesn't work out anybody but I'd
rather think that way about this but do
you think that with computers and things
and then we have to wrap soon to like
his Ray Kurzweil saying things so we're
gonna get immortality through merging
with computers and uploading our I don't
think it's crazy either do you think
there will be a way to upload like who
and what
the hard drives consciousness into hard
drives to extend life yes
realize we no longer use hard drives we
have have you know oh yeah whatever they
it'll media just like move you I use
hard drives I don't be I don't do the
cloud ever so so here I have a rebuttal
to that okay it's a mild rebuttal but
I'm sticking with it all right if I
upload my consciousness to a computer
and computers sitting here on the table
okay and tomorrow I go to the Bahamas
the computer didn't go to the Bahamas so
it's not really me I continue to glean
life experience I meet people that the
computer didn't I have I go swimming and
feel the cold water that the computer
did but what if it Wi-Fi or what if what
if in the connection becomes so good
that instantly like almost like going
out live on YouTube or whatever
instantly you're communicating with the
computer so it's picking up every every
way it's not then the computer is not
just me independent of me it's part of
me fine
okay that but but then all the sudden
was you saying I have little some kind
of electronics in my brain
telepathically communication and then
say you're killed in a boating accident
and then they can build a new you
through your DNA immediately then they
can just upload everything or download
everything from that computer to you so
maybe you lose the last couple of
experiences most of your life is there
but that's still not you that's a you
for everybody else right that's not like
like I principal that in principle if
you could reproduce every single
chemical neurosynaptic configuration in
your brain yeah which itself contains
all your memories in principle you could
just reconstruct a person but that's
still a reconstructed version of you
tempt me why would that's not you like
I'm not immortal it's just see you
wouldn't know you're still the same yeah
yeah why would you even know the
difference yeah I told you
in fact they can remove from your memory
it's ten minutes you didn't exist while
it took it to build you and you wouldn't
even know that it happened like you know
the the prestige you see who's very good
you probably liked it yeah nobody knows
which one's the well I don't know but it
also means in principle can make an
exact copy of you right right yeah yeah
if I figure that out but what's
interesting to me is twins are exact
copies of one another yet they don't
share each other's conscious
consciousness and so usually one has
like a lazy eye or sometimes there's
always a little bit weird to me now of
course they have different fingerprints
but the fingerprints were not
established at the point that the the
genetic code was split that happens
later they do sometimes have that thing
where like one has an itch and the other
fields that write like isn't there sores
that made up I know that's looking at
each other there's something called
mirror neurons do you know about those
no I do but yeah so mirror neurons is it
it's it's suspected that this is very
important with regard to empathy so so
you're there and you scratch your left
arm when I see that I say to you I
wonder if my arm scratches right I start
I start mirroring
what you're doing and it's a sense that
I am feeling what you are experiencing
so that's not a telepathic no that's not
an observer you know you have to observe
it yeah you have to observe it and I'm
Hester mirror right it's in the mirror
and so if something's happening to you
and I have no sense of what's happening
to you then how could I possibly
empathize with your circumstances and
this kind of ties in with one's like are
you on yes this ties in with the
question I know we have to wrap with you
someone you want you know what is this
thing about and I know it's a cop
traveling faster than the speed of light
where there's one where there's like an
atom somewhere and or or whatever it is
and it responds the same way as
something so the information had to
travel faster than the speed of light
you're talking about a coupled particles
okay and so you can put in quantum
mechanics you take two particles that
know about each other's existence
separate them and they still know about
each other's existence and if you
measure one it instantly tells you what
the other one is doing even though you
instantly fact it edit unlimited speed
it could tell you exactly what the other
particle is doing and so these this is a
it's a feature of quantum physics that
people are trying to exploit for
faster-than-light communication I don't
know I don't think it's exploitable but
we've got top people working on it so oh
yeah we'll see oh yeah I've told you I
don't believe the whole speed-of-light
thing is as fast as we're gonna go but
you and I differ on that all right
it's PETA like it's not just a good idea
it's the law